- President of the United States.
(people clapping)
(people cheering)
- [Tarini] This was President
Biden's first official State
of the Union.
- [Senators] Joe, Joe, Joe, Joe.
- The president did not wear a mask.
The mood was definitely very different
from the last joint address.
(Senators cheering)
The address came at a critical
time in his presidency
because the president is still dealing
with the economic uncertainty
that's resulted from the pandemic.
And then, of course, he has
a war in Europe to deal with.
So President Biden had very strong words
for Putin's actions against Ukraine.
- Putin's latest attack on Ukraine
was premeditated and totally unprovoked.
He rejected repeated,
repeated efforts at diplomacy.
He thought the West and
NATO wouldn't respond
but Putin was wrong.
We are ready.
(people clapping)
- [Tarini] He said Russia
would be more isolated
than ever before.
- We're cutting off Russia's largest banks
and international financial system.
- He said the US would
close American airspace
to all Russian air flights.
And then go after Russian oligarchs.
- Seize their yachts,
their luxury apartments,
their private jets.
- [Tarini] As he was talking
about these measures,
we saw bipartisan groups of
lawmakers stand up to applaud.
(people clapping)
- I'm taking robust action
to make sure the pain of our sanctions
is targeted at Russian economy
and that we use every tool at our disposal
to protect American
businesses and consumers.
- He announced one new
measure in his speech.
The US, in addition to 30 other countries,
would be releasing 60
million barrels of oil
from reserves around the world.
- These steps will help blunt
gas prices here at home.
I want you to know we're going to be okay.
- The president also
spent a significant amount
of time in his speech
talking about inflation,
which is at a four-decade high.
So the president bringing up
boosting domestic production.
- Make more cars and
semiconductors in America.
More infrastructure and
innovation in America.
- [Tarini] This was one
of the ways he said the US
could sort of take more control
of the economy coming out
of the pandemic.
- [Senators] USA, USA.
- There's been divisions
related to the pandemic,
whether it's masking, or vaccinations
but he tried to bring the country together
and say it was time to sort
of move past all of that.